flamethrowers are among some of the most
fearsome weapons be that during their
use through history or their betrayals
in our pop culture
so why do so many video game
flamethrowers lack a spark despite the
weapons potential for damage and Chaos
the history of fire as a weapon and the
action and excitement that comes from
throwing flames in a virtual Arena video
games can sometimes struggle to turn up
the heat
so we're going to be shining a light on
the history of the flamethrower both
virtual and otherwise as well as digging
into how games get this iconic weapon so
wrong
foreign
has been used as a weapon for thousands
of years from burning torches and
lengths of wood allowing ancient people
to literally throw fire to flaming
arrows and Siege Weaponry like manganels
and trebuchets but the first weapon we
could consider a flamethrower at least
by modern definition appeared over 1300
years ago Greek fire was an incendiary
weapon utilized by the Byzantine Empire
toward the end of the 7th Century A.D it
was most commonly used in Naval Warfare
where the burning concoction was shot
via a pump and siphon mounted to the bow
of a ship allowing users to spray
burning liquid onto the wooden decks and
holes of opposing vessels from distance
with the mixture continuing to burn even
while floating on water Greek fire was
extremely valuable to the Byzantine
Empire as it was one of their most
powerful weapons with its formula kept a
closely guarded secret because of this
and through the time that has passed the
exact composition has been lost to
history and is still debated today
however we do know that it stayed in use
for hundreds of years to come with 10th
Century military documents detailing a
portable handheld projector to be used
on both land and sea and as a defense
against wooden Siege Towers the
Byzantine Greek Fire hand siphon stands
as the earliest iteration of the
flamethrower but a modern version
wouldn't be seen until the dawn of the
20th century where on the 26th of
February 1915 the German Army first used
the flowers during the first world war
first against French forces outside of a
Dun and again weeks later on the 30th of
July against British trenches at hyuga
the first concerted use in land Warfare
of flamethrowers is probably the first
world war so 1916 Germany a chat called
Richard Fiedler
comes up with a giant sort of truck size
flamethrower operated by a crew and a
small one and that's the beginning of a
lineage of really quite similar weapons
that consist of a tank style backpack
the next version introduced only the
following year in 1917 is the wex which
is that double donut design quite quite
an efficient design and essentially
ripped off by the Brits as the number
two flamethrower in the second world war
the horrific successes of the
flamethrower would cause the German Army
to adopt flamethrowers across their
front lines they were used primarily
against bunkers pill boxes trenches and
fortifications with the goal of
destroying emplacements or to kill or
flush out their occupants preceding the
advance of the rest of the Infantry by
the war's end they were also being
deployed with similar tactics against
enemy tanks and their crew so the
primary use of flamethrowers right from
the start was against fixed positions
into the second world war with more
mobile Warfare again they're about and
engaging pill boxes hardpoints bunkers
tremendous psychological weapon because
if you're in one of those very defended
positions when that burning liquid comes
at you you're quite likely to hide
you're very very you're definitely going
to keep put your head down and not shoot
back you may well flee but if you stay
where you are you know all the oxygen is
going to be removed from the space
that's being attacked you're going to
get burnt by the fuel if you get it on
you getting it off you is going to be
very difficult yeah a bad time
do it
while their effectiveness became clear
so too did the disadvantages of hauling
a big old tank of flammable liquid
across a battlefield there were heavy
large and cumbersome and while weapon
ranges could vary from 18 to 30 meters
their visible spouts of flame meant that
Defenders would immediately Focus rifle
and machine gun fire on the area of a
flamethrower attack the flamethrower's
physical and psychological effect was so
horrible some Allied generals and
politicians reportedly labeled the
device as inhuman and General Pershing
stated that any Soldier caught with one
would be executed although this could
have been political grandstanding in
response to Germany's attempt to ban the
model 97 trench gun and while they may
have first appeared in the first world
war development and Research into
flamethrowers would continue for years
to come and they'd be fielded in
conflicts across the following decades
during World War II both the axes and
allies would issue not only new
infantry-based flamethrower weapons but
also developed flame tanks and other
vehicles to use across the front lines
across the following decades through
World War II to the Korean and Vietnam
Wars the U.S continued to make use of
these weapon systems the Infantry
systems were eventually deemed of
questionable Effectiveness in Modern
Combat and since 1978 flamethrowers have
not been in American Military arsenals
while they may not be a common sight
today short of their civilian use of
controlled burning and agriculture due
to their infamy and impact across
history it's no surprise that the
flamethrower has blazed the trail into
our pop culture flamethrowers have
featured in our games for decades from
the pixelated Embers of flaming side
scrollers to military Shooters and RTS
titles
foreign
but the design performance and
implementation can vary pretty wildly
it's common to see virtual flamethrowers
perform closer to an overcharged
blowtorch than anything resembling their
real-life counterparts with players
spraying wildly and having to move into
as close range as possible in an attempt
to ignite their Foe and it's likely that
this is due to game designers taking
inspiration from Hollywood HotShots over
history
many film Productions especially in the
early days of Cinema used either propane
or petroleum-based flamethrowers
creating either short-ranged bursts of
burning gas or slightly longer streams
of burning liquid fuel compared to the
intense long ranges of sticky burning
Napalm that real flamethrowers would
produce these were much easier to
operate and safer for users actors and
crew as they burned out much quicker and
could be extinguished much easier there
are some exceptions like the 1982 horror
Legend the thing that made use of a
military-grade flamethrower or more
recent Productions like once upon a time
in Hollywood
so it's not surprising that many video
game flamethrowers have followed the
same trend of blowtorch blasts or
shorter streams that burn out quickly
but for potentially different reasons
first is the potential extra
computational Demands a flamethrower
could present I'm sure you can imagine
what streams of liquid napalms sticking
and moving over level geometry with long
burning black smoke spewing Flames could
do to a game's frame rate or Graphics if
Flames burn out quickly have less
interaction with the environment or even
disappear as a player responds than
those previous potential gameplay issues
can be avoided of course this
implementation of flamethrowers can also
affect how they feel when playing with
them in games while in reality the
flamethrower's focus was more on
attacking structures and emplacements in
games it's almost always a weapon to
burn away things of a more organic
nature
be that enemy infantry in the familiar
grounded settings of World War One to
Vietnam or Beyond more bizarre locales
like space-faring ships or alien worlds
or the foul-fettered home of a twisted
family in Louisiana
which brings us to gameplay balance
while some flamethrowers in reality
could cast their fiery payload from
ranges of 20 meters and Beyond virtual
versions often have similar effective
distance to shotguns potentially deadly
up close but leaving enemies barely
breaking a sweat just a few meters away
this demand for such Close Quarters
combat becomes all the more frustrating
in games where players can injure
themselves with their own blazing Trails
but whenever a flamethrower is involved
it's often advantageous to cover the
area with as much flame as possible as
where they can become most useful is
when the odds are against the player
even if they have to battle with limited
ammunition or overheating mechanics in
single player set Pieces Just a lick of
flame can be enough to dispatch an enemy
often in a sobering screaming fashion
although it is not unusual for that
potency to be then dialed down if the
flamethrower makes it into multiplayer
leaving it as an underused option in the
game's Arsenal with different balance
considerations having to be made such as
the player's armor health or resistances
to make the weapon viable again
however in those moments where you're
beset by hordes of aliens Undead or
something else entirely and where you
are able to take advantage of the video
game flamethrowers damage over time or
after bear mechanics this weapon really
gets the opportunity to shine that being
said according to Max Brooks's Zombie
Survival Guide the only thing worse than
horde of zombies is a horde of flaming
zombies
the weight and size of the flamethrower
is something else many games have to
work around even when larger more
realistic models are used they aren't
usually as cumbersome as the real deal
some titles choose to invent their own
flamethrowers with smaller canisters of
fuel mounted to the weapon in view of
the player this goes some way into
separating them from real depictions of
the weapons but also offers up
opportunities to reload while also
downsizing the device into the size of a
rifle or light machine gun rather than
something that is strapped to your back
all of which leads us to the pressurized
fuel-filled elephant in the room if a
player sees that big old backpack
they're gonna want to shoot it aim for
their fuel tanks that should slow them
down
I know I would feel vulnerable with
quite a lot of flammable liquid on my
back
especially if I had to stand up to use a
flamethrower but I remember my
MythBusters and the chances of igniting
the contents of a flamethrower tank seem
to be quite low that said you could of
course use deliberately use incendiary
or explosive ammunition intending to
blow blow up a flamethrower user but if
you have standard ball ammunition I
think it seems that the chance is
getting the right fuel air mixture in
the tank for it to actually go up is
very very difficult if not practically
impossible to do intriguingly our lpo50
does have a through and through bullet
Pole through one of the tanks so I don't
know if the mod were experimenting at
some point or what but it didn't blow up
almost all games that feature a
flamethrowing enemy will grant the
player the option of detonating their
fuel-filled canisters sometimes with
that angle of attack being easier than
facing the enemy head-on and resulting
in some visceral outcomes
while they may not go boom if you shoot
them in reality and I believe it's
perfectly fine to enjoy their virtual
representations there's no denying that
in the real world the flamethrower is a
truly horrific weapon there are some
games that touch upon this element with
some sobering nudges to the player I
remember playing through a few Shooters
trying out various weapons only for
their flamethrower to give me pause in
games like Call of Duty World at War or
Rising storm Vietnam 2 there is both an
audible and visual reaction to using a
flamethrower there are intense screams
from those you hit and player models can
sometimes be left burnt on the ground
these aren't effects that you
experienced the other 95 of the time or
while you're playing with other weapons
which in turn also makes them and the
flamethrower stick out even more
yeah
it might not be something many of you
think about or even want to think about
while kicking back and playing games but
because of the nature of these weapons
and the harm they cause there is a
perception even within pop culture that
one of the most common video game
weapons is in our reality a war crime
while this isn't strictly the case there
are prohibitions and treaties that apply
to them that aren't a factor with
traditional Firearms there have been
specific efforts to try to restrict
these weapons there's Treaty 22495 of
the 1980 the United Nations convention
on certain Conventional Weapons this is
quite vague though it's not specific to
flamethrowers it wasn't signed up to by
Everyone by any means the United States
only signed up to it in 2008 would you
believe China for example still has
flamethrowers in its inventory and is
not a signatory to that there's nothing
stopping anyone who didn't sign up to it
from using flamethrowers now by Common
convention they are no longer used
that's probably the strongest protection
we have from them is that they're just
really bad press so they've kind of gone
away before they've been fully nailed
down as something that Humanity no
longer wants to have
video games are fun escapism and I'll
repeat my earlier sentiment that there's
nothing wrong with playing any shooter
you want with whatever weapon you want
we can find video game flamethrowers fun
while also knowing that in the real
world they really suck but with that in
mind I do think it's interesting that
the shared comprehension and recognition
that people have around the flamethrower
as well as how it was phased out in
reality may have somewhat helped shape
its life and reception in video games
games that use historical battlefields
as a backdrop May often feature
real-world examples of flamethrowers
that fit into the time period
Battlefield 1 features the world war one
wex as the flame Troopers inventory Call
of Duty World at War allows players to
use the American M2 from the second
world war with its replacement the US M9
flamethrower being carried into the
1960s as the intense and effective
version found in Rising Storm 2 Vietnam
there are of course moments famous
through the history of video games where
the flamethrower is Twisted into
absurdity in comic contrast to the
weapon's Grim reality
flamethrower I'm sure we all remember
Far Cry 3 where it's used as a tool to
burn down marijuana plants to the
soundtrack of roaring flame and dubstep
number three
but when unique universes have styles
and stories of their own the idea of a
flamethrower is so broad that it can
find a place pretty much anywhere even
if it's not always the best weapon
available from post-apocalyptic heavy
weapons wielded by power armor Troopers
as they explored Mojave or Twisted into
Worlds that are more comical and
stylized of course the most famous of
all being Team Fortress 2's
asbestosu-clad mumbling mercenary
specializing in Hit and Run tactics and
returning Rockets descender with a blast
of unignited gas
but there is one genre with a burning
torch of a flamethrower can be your
light of Salvation from the encroaching
dark
all right I'm talking about horror
fire has been used to combat All Things
That Go Bump in the night since the
Inception of the genre and the
flamethrower exists as a larger and more
fearsome extension of that
for Millennia fire has been used to ward
off creatures that could do us harm and
in many horror games the flamethrower
can be used to that effect most notably
against the xenomorph in Alien Isolation
with those brief bursts of flame being
the only weapon capable of scaring off
the alien
the psychological response to fire is a
natural and somewhat relatable one
because we've been burned before I
believe our imaginations can more easily
extrapolate that feeling into having
some small sense of what it may feel
like being on the receiving end of this
weapon
to me because the virtual flamethrower
feels that bit more intense and horrific
than most other video game weapons it
makes it easier to turn the weapon
against manifestations of fear and
horror from hordes of shambling Undead
or victims of umbrella corporations
experiments to the wicked beasts of
yharnam or even the Grim dark creatures
of the 41st Millennium the more horrific
they are the easier they are to put to
the torch foreign
the horror genre is a great example of
how games and pop culture showcase the
flamethrower within the context of their
own remarkable universes as a tool to
combat hellish monsters detaching
themselves from the weapons hellish
reality
while the flamethrower is an iconic
video game weapon it's safe to say that
its Effectiveness has flickered
throughout its virtual life in a handful
of games it's a Powerhouse of
Destruction while and many more it's
often easily outclassed or extremely
situational games understandably shy
away from the unpleasant realism of the
weapon instead opting for pop culture
flamethrowers that both in function and
form largely exist as very different
entities while still giving their
players a touch of the intensity that
comes with having the gift of Prometheus
in the palm of their hand
thank you so much for watching this
episode of Loadout if you enjoyed it
please make sure to like the video and
subscribe and maybe even let me know
your favorite video game flamethrowers
in the comments section below be sure to
tell us what else you'd like to see
Loadout cover and if you want more video
game Firearms content you can watch the
previous episodes of this show or check
out our weekly series of firearms expert
reacts where I show our friends at the
Royal armories a selection of guns from
our favorite games until next time I've
been your host Dave Jewett and I'll see
you in the next one
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]